الان الى ااا العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس التي
تشهد اجتماع للوزراء الخارجيه
العرب
والكلمه الان لنجلاء المنكوش وزيره
الخارجيه الليبيه
الساده الحضور المحترمون اهلا بكم حللتم
اهلا على شعب ليبيا الذي افتقد التضامن
العربي
لثنوات فاهلا بمن حضر لاجله اخوتي نرحب
بكم اليوم في العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس
الامن المستقر
كمان يرحم
ترحيب الخاص بالمبعوث الاممي السيد بتيلي
الذي يلعب دورا مهما وحيويا في تاريخ
ليبيا
والذي ستعد ايضا بمداخلته بعد قليل
وايضا الترحيب والتقدير موصول لمبعوثه
الاتحاد الاوروبي السيده وحيده على
تواجدها معنا اليوم
اولئك الذين لم يتخلوا يوما عن فلسطين
وشعبها في زمن النكبه وبايام انتفاضات
الشعب الفلسطيني ومتلاها من احداث الجسام
في زمن التحرير والثوره
وشاركوا بلدان الخليج العربي
ابناء الشام والعراق ومصر استقلال ليبيا
وبناء دولتها الحديثه مرورا بالعقود
التاليه
الكريمه مستقره ومساهمه الليبيين في
البناء والتنميه فكانت ليبيا دائما ارضا
لكل العرب
ولم يتوقف سعي ابناء شعبي على الدوام عن
نصره قضايا العرب في كل المراحل ورغم كل
ظروفنا وبكل العهود السابقه نحن شعب لا
يحقد ولا يكره جيب لنا على نصره المظلوم
وان اصابنا وهن وتفرقنا فان وحده شعب
ليبيا هي امر محتوم بالنسبه لنا فقط هي
مساله وقت وستتحقق
ان التضامن العربي اليوم هو اخر فرص امتنا
لايجاد طريقه امل قد تنعش فرص استعاده
النظام العربي الرسمي للثقه شعوبنا
والاتجاه بها للتنميه والتفاهم والوحده
بدلا عن الفرقه والتضيق على مصالح شعوبنا
المشتركه لاسباب سياسيه
لاسباب سياسيه تمزق امتنا العربيه فلا
مصلحه لشعوبنا في التشكيك في قدرته على
حمايه الترابطها رغم كل التحديات الحضور
الكريم ان اجتماعنا التشاور المفتوح الغير
رسمي اليوم في طرابلس وبمشاركه الامم
المتحده واتحاد الافريقي يتناغم مع اتفاق
وزراء الخارجيه العرب في فبراير
2021 على اهميه تكثيف الاجتماعات
التشاوريه وقد سبق للاشقاء في قطر استضافه
اجتماع تشاوري في اليونيو 2021 اثناء
رئاسه دوله قطر الدوريه لمجلسنا الموقر
ولاحقا استضافته الكويت
وبعد ذلك بيروت رغم كل التحديات
هذه الاجتماعات التشاوريه مماثله لم يكن
هناك دعوات لتاجيلها او ثني وزراء خارجيه
الدول العربيه ذات سياده عن زياره هذه
العواصم العربيه دعما للتضامن العربي
واعاده الامل لشعوبنا في قدره منظومه
العرب العمل العربي المشترك على الاستمرار
موحده والعمل بمسؤوليه في هذه المرحله
التاريخيه بالنسبه لمنطقتنا وشعبنا
ناكد اليوم اصرار دوله ليبيا على ممارسه
حقوقها الكامله في جامعه الدول العربيه
التي تدفع فيها مساهماتنا الكامله ولا
نعترف بان يكون هناك تمييز بين اعضائها
بين جهه الحقوق والواجبات
رافدين تاسيس قواعد العمل وميثاق لوائح
جامعه الدول العربيه التي لانى بها موقع
ودور تاريخي لن تناله دعوات التشكيك قدرات
ليبيا لاستضافه اشقائها
اليوم نحن نسجل فصلا جديدا من فصول تاريخ
العمل العربي المشترك نكتب تفاصيله وقد
اصابت بعد ابناء شعبنا في ليبيا خيبه
الامل وقد تابعوا كيف استكثر عليه البعض
ان تستضيف طرابلس اجتماعا تشاوريا عربيا
قد لا يتجاوز زمن عقاده السعاده
من الدول الاعضاء بشكل مرن لمتابعه
مستجدات القضايا العربيه الراهنه او التي
تتفاعل منذ عقود
يا عمري ان الشعوب العراق وفلسطين وسوريا
وجزر القمر وجبوتي واليمن والسودان
والصومال
لابد وانها تستعيد اليوم بكل اسف سوابق
مماثله لم تكن فيها العطر العربيه الرسميه
منحازه او متعاطفه مع قضاياها هذه شعوب
طالب دوما باحترام تمثيلها داخل جامعه
الدول العربيه وان تتلقى دعما عربيا رسميا
تلمسه واقعا ملموسا داخل عواصم دولنهم
اجتماع الى التشاور اليوم هو مساحه مفتوحه
للنقاش حول قضايا شعوبنا وتحقيق امالها في
مستقبل عادل ومشرق للاجيال القادمه
اليوم وبدل من النعل من خلال المؤسسات
جامعه الدول العربيه عن نجاحنا في اطلاق
رؤيه عربيه موحده للتعامل مع قضايا
العربيه
نجد هناك بعض المحاولات لكسر اراده
الليبيين المتطلعه لتحويل التضامن العربي
مع ليبيا الى واقع ملموس
عبر استعاده الدور العربي في تدعيم
الاستقرار بليبيا والمساهمه في الجهود
الدوليه نحو دعم مسار اجراء انتخابات
الوطنيه بها ورعايه التحول الديمقراطيه
التي تصاحبه تحديات الكبيره لا ننكرها
ونتعامل معها بشجاعه وعقلانيه وقد زادنا
قوه في هذا الصدد تضامن اشقائنا العرب ممن
دعم حضوره بشكل شخصيه وبكل قوه في كافه
المحافل العربيه وبالقمه العربيه في
الجزائر رغم محاولات التمييز والاستهداف
لعرقله هذا الدور في عدم استعاده شعب
ليبيا لاستقرار بلاده وحمايه مصالحه
واجراء انتخابات وطنيه
الساده الوزراء اصحاب السعاده المحترمون
ان حكومه الوحده الوطنيه حافظت على تقديم
الخدمات الاساسيه لكل ابناء ليبيا بجميع
مناطقها وانها وصولها للسلطه حاله
الاقتتال بينهم ولاول مره منذ عشر سنوات
اصبحت سائر بلديات ليبيا تقدم الخدمات
الاساسيه لكل الليبيين وتم تفعيل الاداره
المحليه بعد سنوات من توريط البلديات في
الانقسام السياسي والحروب وبشرنا اجراء
الانتخابات البلديه على ان تستكمل
الانتخابات بالبلديات التي انتهت مده
ولايتها خلال العام الجاري كما شاهد
الاقتصاد الوطني مدفلام الحكومه لمهامها
تعافيا
مدفوعا بجمله من الاجراءات على مستوى
السياسه النقديه والماليه والاقتصاديه
فعلى مستوى السياسه الماليه انعكس حجم
الانفاق الاستثماري بنحو 17 مليار دينار
على عوده الحياه لمشروعات التنميه التي
متوقفه منذ عام 2011
والتوسع في المشروعات الاستراتيجيه مثل
الكهرباء والطاقه وتقليص العجز في طاقه
التوليد نجحت حكومه الوحده الوطنيه ان
تحافظ على تدفق انتاج النفط وتخصيص
ميزانيه استثنائيه للمؤسسه الوطنيه للنفط
بقيمه 34 مليار دينار تسهم في رفع معدلات
الانتاج الى اكثر من مليون
عفوا مليون
واربعه فاصله برميل يوميا
كمساهمه الجهود المشتركه بين حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه
خلال الفتره من الاستقرار سوق السلع
والخدمات وسوق الصرف الاجنبي واحتواء
الضغوط وتضخميه الناتجه عن الازمه الماليه
العالميه وتمكن المصرف المركزي من القضاء
على مشكله السيوله التي كانت تواجه القطاع
المصري
وتمكن المصرف المركزي ايضا من كل التحديات
التي تواجه الاقتصاد الليبي اليوم وهو
اقتصاد الواعد بالفرس الاستثماريه التي
تمثل فرصا واعده لمن يريد مصلحه شعوب
المنطقه وان تكون التنميه مدخل الاستقرار
في ليبيا اليوم اجدد استمرار تعهد حكومتنا
باجراء الانتخابات في ليبيا احتراما
لاراده اكثر من اثنين مليون و500,000 ناخذ
استلموا بطاقاتهم انتخابيه وقد نفذتت
الحكومه في نوفمبر الماضي محاكاه للعمليه
الانتخابيه بحضور سفراء الدول شريكه
الليبيين في دعم الاستقرار كما تواصل
التامها بانهاء المراحل الانتقاليه
والحفاظ على استقرار اوضاع ليبيا ومنع
انزلاقها للفوضى التي قد تقود استقرار دول
الجوار العربي والافريقي وكذلك الاوروبي
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه نجحت العام الماضي
في تنظيم احتفاليه طرابلس عاصمه الاعلام
العربي لسنه 2022 بعد تسميه جامعه الدول
العربيه لها واختتمت ليبيا هذه الفاعليه
باستضافه طرابلس لاجتماع تشاور الوزراء
الاعلام العرب في ذكرى استقلال ليبيا في
24 ديسمبر وقد شاهدت طرابلس على مدار
العام حضورا عربيا مكفانا لم تشهده منذ 10
سنوات
لاستضافه اشقائهم العرب
ان اسرار حكومه الوحده الوطنيه على ان
يكون بجامعه الدول العربيه دور في دعم
تعافي ليبيا مؤسس على محوريه دور جامعه
الدول العربيه في القضيه الليبيه ودورها
في سنه 2011 في مساله دعم التدخل الدولي
في ليبيا فلا يمكن اليوم ابعاد الجامعه
العربيه عن لعب دور ايجابي في دعم جهود
الشركاء الدوليين ليبيا والذي لمسه جديد
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه على انحاء المراحل
الانتقاليه
وعليه فان فاعليه وجديه الدور العربي في
مساعده ليبيا يجب ان يكون بحجم تفاعل
الامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي وشركاء
ليبيا الدوليين في طريق دعم اجراء
الانتخابات وكذلك دعم جهود البعثه الاميه
للدعم في ليبيا وجهود المصالحه الوطنيه
التي يقودها المجلس الرئاسي ان التقدم
الذي حققه المجلس الرئاسي في مسار
المصالحه الوطنيه في ليبيا يستحق الاشاده
وق هذا العالم قبل ايام مبادره نائب رئيس
المجلس الرئاسي السيد عبد الله اللافي وقد
توجت بجمع ممثلين عن جميع الاطراف
السياسيه في ليبيا اجتمعوا في طرابلس
المستقره وتحت راح رايه واحده وبلد واحد
ناقشوا كل القضايا الجوهريه موضوع النقاش
والخلاف بين الليبيين ولن يتوقف هذا
المسار طالما امن الليبيين امن الليبيين
بالاحتكام بالحوار ورفض دفعهم للاقتال
مجددا الحضور المحترمون هناك تضامن واسع
لدبلوماسيين وادباء ورجال اعمال ومؤثرين
عرب وغربيين مع الشعب الليبي والذين زاروا
ليبيا طيله السنه الماضيه تحدثوا عن قصص
ملهمه وعايش وكيف يقاوم الشعب الليبي
محاولات جره للحرب
اسرار الليبيين على المذي قدما نحو السلام
هذه السرديه التي يدعوكم اليوم بان تطلع
على تفاصيلها من خلال حضوركم وزياره
ترابلس وليست تكسرديه سلبيه التي تحاول
تنميط الحاله الليبيه على انها حاله حرب
مستمره ونسف المتواصل الدماء لا تصدق تلك
القصص السلبيه المرعبه التي تصف طرابلس او
ليبيا بانها ارض حروب ودمار في محاوله
لتكرار رسم السور السوداويه والسلبيه التي
رسمت لعقود لعواصم عربيه اخرى عانت محن
واهوال وحروب وتعقيدات سياسيه بعضها تعافى
ولا يزال البعض مصر على تخويف منها ليبيا
لها وجوه جميله وشعبها نبيل وشجاع نكتب
سويه قصه صمودنا واملنا وتضحياتنا من اجل
بلادنا ليكن لها جاذبيه واثر لكل شعوب
الارض ولا نتجاهل التوجيه الديني بان
مثلنا كمثل الجسد الواحد اتمشتك منه عضو
تداعى له سائر الجسد بالسهر والحمى
فالشعوب لن يوقف ارتباطها احد
يمنع تعاطفها مع قضاياها قرار او ضغوط
السياسيه اليوم هناك اختبار علني امام
الشعوب العربيه حول مدى جديه جامعه الدول
العربيه والنظام العربي الرسمي في تحقيق
التضامن العربي المشترك نامو لليوم الا
نغيب امل الشعوبنا التي ستقلق على مصيرها
ان شهدت انقسام العرب اذا مساله تنظيميه
ودعم الاجتماع تشاوري مفتوح موسع مرن
باجنده عربيه جامعه
ختاما تاكيدا لاستقرار طرابلس وثبات خطوات
الليبيين تجاه الاستقرار يشاركنا هذا
الاجتماع التشاوري العربي المبعوث الخاص
للامين العام للامم المتحده السيد عبد
الله باتيري هذا الدبلوماسي الافريقي
القريب الى شعبنا وصديقه الذي لم يغادر
ليبيا بعد تعيينه في منصبه الى وجهات
خارجيه الا بعد ان استمع الى الليبيين
واقام بينهم واعلن عن اقامته الدائمه داخل
ليبيا على عكس مسؤولون امويين سابقين هذا
التوجه الفريد قطع الطريق على من يحاول ان
ينقل صوره دائمه القتامه حول ليبيا
ومستقبل التحول الديمقراطي بها ادعوا
جامعه الدول العربيه الى دعم جهوده
الراميه لتفعيل دور البعثه الاميه لدى
ليبيا في اتجاه تهيئه الظروف لاجراء
الانتخابات وانهاء المراحل الانتقاليه في
ليبيا بشكل سلمي
اود اشكركم مجددا على حضوركم واستماعكم
لكلمتي وقد حرزت ان اكون واضحه ومعبره عن
عداله وقوه حق الليبيين في استعاده دورهم
في محطهم العربي مسؤوليتكم التاريخيه تجاه
اشقائكم في هذه المرحله المهمه من تاريخ
ليبيا شكرا جزيلا
اذا تابعنا واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام انطلاق
اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه العرب في طرابلس
والكلمه قبل قليل التي كانت لنجلاء
المنكوش وزيره الخارجيه في حكومه عبد
الحميد
[موسيقى]